so new batch is ordered it will
really take a while until we
have a reasonable number here. losing
the very first batch because of this
software
was expensive fun because otherwise you
always get music directly from 1600 to 2000 and
then it's okay  it's
still going to take a while before you get here
somehow so
matschie well you better not lose now
then we'll sit
tomorrow everything normal moves will be fine
usually running the seven or taking on
the four is also often the case here
I often play knight z2 here, the players
often do not cope well with the
retreat, it is
usually
very helpful for black to exchange at least one knight in the structure
or if it is possible
to exchange even more
if you have a little lack of space
and are frequent  these three rows
for all the figures that you have to
manage like this a little bit later
three that's always a little bit
slanted but I have to cover c4
the point is he can always
attack here again but that is
always only temporary and in the
end the pieces are usually thrown
back
ok quantity voluntarily value back
so I have made my own line-up
that I have here  always play
tower b1 i.e. a b1 and around fc 1 later
,
after detailed preparation, sometimes
like playing four, so the atom sorts the pieces into
new 1s somehow,
but if I’m not quite
sure where
I want to go, I think maybe that was a
putting up the towers a bit earlier
if he makes five then they
actually belong after your son the
1 you have an alternative here
somehow well knights who stop five times
f5 is also weakening
there you didn't beat yourself up
okay that was it  not his plan good
here is the question
normal is eb 5 right here behind
to press seven here my
figures are correct there  here have flights completely
wrong for i suppose so he ca
n't even after five because of r4 because there is no
longer a field on the jumper and it only says bicycle
on it anyway he can
now actually only at eight
that's why cd five years is really
one  idea
like that and now i would have planned
to play it easy with the idea of five knights and i
will also go that way but if he
makes a giant hole here the only
hing you have to survive is knigh
10/15/11 runner b2 if that works someh
w 55 cents for one  so discovers
bitter 2
there
wins a quality but well run
have two ladies b 235 runner h
66 can go back yes probably not the idea
its
yes tries to stuff into the finish line here
somehow and four
probably makes jumper a4 is a
bit stupid but good black
Of course, I can't breed much either, if
I now take such a quiet breed after
which, for example, Springer a4 also
takes off, I don't even know what he then
j  now pulls the seven maybe
leaves me on 26
in not really bad
i think but now the question is the
sixth idea for him actually no
longer i can open with the lady
double the sum on the cd in her
a little gas  mainly give a
difference in playing strength over time you
can always lose how is it because
now here could be a gymnastics club
and then the farmer who shows
up I
have no idea at 4 how well I supported back then
I'm just like that toni 84
Of course I do
n't have to win c the pawn before he plays b4 himself so in
order to ruin the black squares
so now I thought spider has to
do here and now the club is I have the
finish line and c6 is not only a
square for knights but also for
tours  the only thing that's a bit
missing here are levers that are constantly in the
position
so i can't
pry them open well or anywhere ok
yes yes yes gu  t i had to come to the
company you don’t like it that much
the black forest runner will of
course be very strong here now but i
didn’t have a big alternative to it is
also not yet
clear what he wants to do with the runner now so
not even that  field better away 5
through then runner f3 still or
dvd 34 to cover because at that time 7
he has pleasantly on the clock and
caught up so always here
to be on the safe side cover what the queen can also draw and now maybe you can now
force the ladies to swap here or  it
was a dumb breed i see right now he
can play next to and jumper here
four because of the year the runners okay
so turn around but not done
which make runners 63 before christmas
because he is really playing very
slowly now so yes i do the field have eight
jumpers  82 I was so
fascinated by how slowly he played I
didn't really pay attention anymore
but okay I can't miss b5
further bad because he will now exceed the time
wolfs ontario 1600